what's up everybody I'm Emily from Pond
phenotype and welcome to another episode
of challenge pump Italy this is the
series where you challenge us with your
craziest ideas relate to do table tennis
we'll go through all of your comments
pick the most credit once and make a
video out of them if you're already a
gets picked we'll feature in the video
and give you a shout out so be sure to
leave your ideas in the comment section
below
okay first up is a Facebook comment that
comes from Gregory sellers break a
single stick of spaghetti by smashing it
from ten meters away and then have ten
sticks and smash those from one meter
away this will be an interesting one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right next up a spin and only from
one meter away oh that was quite a few
oh let's take all of them by one really
good
[Music]
let's try to hit them one more time okay
shark light wants the mass of ping-pong
ball over three times on the water this
reminds me a bit of throwing rocks on
the water like this I have no idea how
this will work the ping pong ball but
let's find that out
I'll give it five shots
initially first
[Music]
that was three or four maybe
let's go start
second
okay the third one
[Music]
then fourth one
okay then the last one pick one I
started getting five
[Music]
oh I think no it's for maybe we'll have
to check the GoPro camera
they stole more camera to see if there
was four or five but at least we got
three that sharkbite wanted
[Music]
[Music]
so this is our pumpkin let's try to see
if we can do any damage on it with
something pumpkins
[Music]
I'm making more damage on the GoPro down
the pump
[Music]
so as you can see the pumpkin survived
it's still smiling nothing much happened
with it but it was fun to try out thanks
for watching I had a fun time filming
this video outside here in Finland
although it's only a couple of degrees
right now but if you enjoyed the video
leave a thumbs up and if you're new to
the channel subscribe right here and
watch the previous episodes here until
next time
[Music]